اذا تكتمل بعد قليل مناوره الالتحام مع
محطه الفضاء الدوليه لمهمه رواد الفضاء
السعوديان على الجرني وريان البرناوي على
متن المركبه دراغون والتي انطلقت امس من
مركز كنيدي الفضائي في فلوريدا بمهمه
فضائيه مشاهدينا يشارك فيها ايضا رائده
فضاء اخرين هما
من الولايات المتحده الامريكيه زي
المشاهدين كما ذكرنا تكتمل بعد قليل
مناورات الالتحام مع محطه الفضاء الدوليه
لمهمه رواد الفضاء السعوديان على القرني
وريان برناوي على متن المركبه دراغون
الفضاء مشاهدينا انطلقا علامات الصاروخ
ايضا التابع لشركه
والمملوكه
في رحله تنظمها شركه اكسيوم سبيس ونذكر
ايضا مشاهدينا بان رحله رايداي الفضاء
السعوديين تاتي ضمن برنامج المملكه لرواد
الفضاء الذي يهدف
للتاهيل كوادر السعوديه متمرسه لخوض رحلات
فضائيه
وللمشاركه ايضا في اجراء التجارب العلميه
والابحاث الدوليه والمهام المستقبليه
المتعلقه بقطاع الفضاء سنكون معكم
مشاهدينا في متابعه للحظه التحام مع محطه
الفضاء الدوليه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات